English Subtitles by Precious Torres & Alen Alic
-
Ethan: Welcome, everybody, to the H3 Podcast with a very, very special guest.
In town for Vidcon is your boy: Boogie.
Boogie:  Well, to be honest with you, I'm actually here for this podcast. VidCon's this oth-
Ethan: Haha, yeah!
Boogie: I'll be honest with you, when we were planning Vidcon this year, you mentioned the podcast to me like
six months ago and said, "Do you want to be on it?" and I'm like, "The next time I'm in LA."
But that's the entire thing I thought the whole time.
And I was afraid to approach you.
I was like, "I'm gonna DM him and just demand to be on it!"
But I'm like, "I know he's busy, I know it's like-"
Ethan: No!
Boogie: You've got SoFlo this Friday, isn't it?
Hila: Steve-O.
Ethan: Steve-O this Friday, SoFlo next Friday.
Boogie: Right, so you've got a packed schedule anyway...
Ethan: We can fit you in! Any time!
Boogie: Well not a lot of people can. I'm a big guy.
Ethan & Hila: (laughing)
I don't know if your listeners know that. But I happen to be a little extra wide.
Ethan: We got all the space you need, buddy.
Hila: Yep.
Ethan: Well, for me, it's like, I know you don't - you don't
get the opportunity to come out to LA frequently.
Although you have been traveling more lately.
Boogie: Well, we've been trying to.
Ethan: Yeah.
Boogie: But this body does not like it very much anymore.
Boogie: Its started to - you know.. (sigh)
It's been a downhill battle.
I'd like to say uphill battle.
But it's been a downhill battle over the last couple of years.
Uh, with diabetes getting worse, blood pressure, and everything else, so -
Uh, it's difficult to even really leave the house anymore.
This busted out back, these busted knees, and stuff like that.
Hila: Wow.
Boogie: Um, but, we push it to its absolute limits and we try to come out to LA at least twice a year.
Ethan: Mm.
Boogie: At least for the game awards and at least for VidCon.
Boogie: I think - I don't know if your listeners know this,
but I'm scheduled for a gastric bypass on July 25th.
Ethan: Yes!
Ethan: Yeah, I -
Boogie: And it was a three year process to qualify.
Ethan: Holy shit!
Hila: Wow.
Boogie: Yeah, so we had to lose a ton of weight,
Boogie: uh, to get down to an ideal weight.
Ethan: So, when you decided that you wanted the gastric bypass surgery -
Boogie: Yeah?
Ethan: How much weight did you need to lose since then?
Boogie: Well, okay - well, the very - when I knew I was going -
When I finally came to terms with the fact that I would need gastric bypass, that was thirteen years ago.
Hila: Wow.
Ethan: Oh, shit.
Boogie: But then, financially, I couldn't afford it to begin with.
Ethan: How much is it?
Boogie: Um, well, thirteen years ago, you're talking $50, $60,000, you know?
Ethan: Pffft! / Hila: Oh my god.
Boogie: Right? And that's just, like, absurd, and I couldn't get insurance.
The only work I could get was part-time, and generally that's through nepotism, through friends and stuff.
Ethan: Yeah.
Boogie: Because people don't want to put me on their health insurance.
Boogie: That's crazy, right?
Ethan: Right.
Hila: Mhm.
Boogie: And so I knew that was the first step: to finally get enough money in the bank to pay for it.
So, uh, the doctor I'm working with -
if you're living in the Northwest Arkansas region,
Dr. Purner is an amazing doctor.
Ethan: Shout out!
Boogie: Um, he managed to cut me a really nice deal.
Boogie: It's right under $20,000. And it's out of pocket, you know but -
Ethan: Do you have health insurance?
Boogie: I do. We bought the best possible package Arkansas offers.
But they don't want to pay for that surgery.
Ethan: Interesting.
Boogie: They consider it to be a cosmetic surgery.
Hila: Really?
Boogie: Which sounds like lunacy to me because it will save them millions.
Boogie: You know, if they were doing that surgery - pay $18,000 to keep me from having a stroke or a heart attack.
Hila: Yeah.
Boogie: How much is that going to cost you?
But, you know, politics aside...
Uh, then I